so Alan while you are at the hollywood
reporter as a lead film critic what did
that teach you about removing the film
such a tricky thing yeah think about the
film of making it and the real work
comes really promoting ain't getting out
there so what what did you see that
worked
I think promotion always works it always
brings attention whether an audience
wants to stay for that attention stay
for the movie once it's been brought
there is a different matter you know
promotion is as old as the hills I mean
it's it's handbills Flyers television
Internet it's just the venues have
changed the way in which it's
accomplished the what those those ways
have changed but it's the same thing as
looking for the hook to bring the
audience's attention what is the hook
what can be sold it's interesting I mean
certainly at that time in the seventh is
you could sell a film because it was the
work of a certain filmmaker the
Hollywood Giants were the very end of
their careers and the new serious
filmmakers were at the beginning of
their careers though so there were about
50 to 60 movies a year that you had to
see you had to see those movies because
they were made by serious filmmakers
that statistic has gone way down no
going back to what you say the hook for
Bob's new suit who's the audience
will really resonate with the film Bob's
new suit was made for all audiences that
was my intention that it was that it
could have that it would that it would
literally have something for everyone
it's it's just it's a movie about a
family the language is a little rough
for younger members of a family
certainly the GLBT audience is drawn to
this film I've also found that older men
and women are very drawn to it people of
my generation are very drawn to it and
we'll see we'll see who really comes
you